because look at the bat ito could I
remind you that the debate will finish
at 20 past 11:00 today because then I
will be going to welcome the president
of Angola and the you can enroll
according to the usual system using your
card and pressing the appropriate button
the floor
son of the Bunya shivani's president tie
Annie Minister Ashdod Luke so after
buying up shop carrying s deadline he
was supposed to be here mr. Dombrowski's
members of the European Parliament
ladies and gentlemen it's an honor for
me as the Prime Minister of the Polish
government to have the opportunity to
speak to you here in Strasbourg and to
give you the Polish point of view on the
challenges that face the European
Parliament it's also an honor to speak
to the European Parliament amongst all
of the EU institutions it is the
Parliament that reflects the voice of
its citizens expressed in universal
elections the European Parliament is an
important part of the EU s-- functioning
not just because it has an enormous
influence on the shape of european
legislation but also because it's a
forum in which discussions take place
that set the course for the european
union for the next few years
Poland is celebrating the five hundred
and fiftieth anniversary its first
Parliament and the hundredth anniversary
of his independence we were one of the
first countries to give full democratic
rights to women as well and this shows
how Poland has deep roots in
parliamentarism and the rule of law
national parliaments are the voice of
the sovereign and the lifeblood of
democracy the discussion on the future
of Europe is one of the most important
debates that we can have particularly on
this the 100th anniversary of the end of
the First World War which began very
difficult history of the 20th century in
Europe the cataclysms of two world wars
and the genocide all cried the crimes
saw the free countries begin with a
historic project 60 years
aiming to find what could bring us
together if it hadn't been for the Iron
Curtain and the tragic division of
Europe Poland would also have been one
of the founding fathers of the European
community that's what the Polish
government-in-exile had wanted at the
time Polish society was therefore kept
outside of the first stage in in
European integration and sustainable
development so now as a fully fledged
member of the EU we want to do our bit
to aim to create a constructive program
for the future of our continent we have
our expectations as every country in the
European Union does but we also have
plenty to offer you can't understand the
continuity of Europe without
understanding its Greek Roman and
judeo-christian roots without those we
would never have achieved what we have
achieved today this feeling of
universalism for example you can see
here the diversity that we cherish now
these slogans are not just empty words
in Europe our continent has been shaped
by its culture and institutions over
hundreds of years and respecting
national identities is part of the trust
that must be built in the EU
constitutional pluralism in article 4 of
the treaty is one of the great values of
the EU and every country has a right to
set up its legal system in line with its
own traditions the idea of Europe for me
was always a reason of state as a young
man I was part of the anti-communist
opposition fighting for freedom and demo
democracy but the same went for my work
in the in European integration committee
working on Poland's accession to the EU
in the 90s 30 years since the fall of
communism we're still part of a
difficult process of sewing together
different parts of Europeans history and
memory but we mustn't lose sight of the
joint goal which is the safety and
security of our citizens and economic
development members of the house in the
last few years the European Union has
been dealing with a number of
existential crisis the financial crisis
the banking crisis
the eurozone crisis the migration crisis
brexit or Russian aggression 5 nose in
referendums and a change in the
political landscape in Member States all
of these things go to show that the
European project needs a new openness
some have said that the European Union
always go through crises and all changes
to the treaties were arise from those
crises and reinforce it however the
situation today seems to be without
precedent different to the 70s or the
80s or the first decade of this century
that's because it's not just one crisis
but accumulation of several crises
happening at the same time and any
response to those crises has to be based
on a sound understanding of the
circumstances in which we find ourselves
we know that a lot of Europeans aren't
so enthusiastic about in theater
integration anymore and some are
outright against you can be offended by
that you can close your eyes to it you
can say it's just a marginal group but
it's not going to change the reality of
the fact that it's not a marginal group
this is a real message that we've made
mistakes and that we have to correct
those mistakes instead of wringing our
hands about the threat we should start
thinking about how we got into this
situation where many Europeans no longer
like the direction of the EU is going in
the answer to that question has been
given many times and in many ways but I
think that the best answer is to be
found in all of the major changes in our
history people have a freedom gene in
their DNA they want to decide on their
future their children's future their
family's future their society's future
for themselves and when they see that
they're losing that influence and that
they don't have any influence on the
future of Europe in the world then
they're going to oppose what's happening
I think that we all agree more or less
that European integration is one of the
most significant phenomena in the
history of not only Europe but the world
however if citizens don't share that
view then no further integration can be
possible therefore their voice has to be
taken into account if the European
project is to move forward therefore
it's democratic democratic legitimacy
has to be reinforced you can call that
populism if you like but at the end of
the day we're going to have to ask to
the questions asked by citizens and
their expectations it's all about the
very meaning of democracy
Europe is going through a democratic
enlightenment we have to renew
social contract that's been such a
success since the Second World War that
contract meant rebuilding a feeling of
security rebuilding the economy offering
offering prosperity to all today we need
a an Covenant to annex to that contract
showing that our children will also have
a better life than we had we have to
build confidence in the European project
so how do we how do we answer this
democratic change
well Europe has to be up to the
challenges of the modern age without
giving up on the duties at all as he has
to its citizens to deal with all of
these challenges we have to rebalance
the relationship between the main and
member states and the EU institutions
the union of nations 2.0 according to de
Gaulle's vision is one way of doing this
and that's Poland's proposal an
intelligent adjustment would focus on
three things
first of all a union 4.0 would be a
bridgehead of the industrial of the
fourth Industrial Revolution the second
thing would be a secure European Union
which is aware of the geopolitical
challenges that it faces and have a
single answer to them where we would
speak with one voice
next a union of citizens with solidarity
and supporting our citizens against the
power of global corporations let me just
say a little more about those yes we
need more cooperation when we face the
challenges of the global economy Europe
needs to set ambitious goals and
audacious budgets for the single market
the finalization of the single market
the increase in productivity can only be
achieved if competitiveness
is increased in a fully integrated
single market according to the European
Parliament's own analysis in the last 14
years it has contributed to a growth in
GDP of 250 billion euro ceteris paribus
services for example are responsible for
70% of the union's GDP but only 25% of
trade within the EU the services
directed from 2006 needs to be revised
so that it can reflect the services as
they are provided today they can't be a
single market unless we fight the
disparities if we have unless we have an
ambitious cohesion policy
this can't be a one-way route for
one-way street for underdeveloped
company that countries it's about
developing the single market which
brings enormous trade benefits to those
including to those who are calling for
it to be limited our calculations and
the union's own calculations show that
75 cents in every euro go back to Neto
payers in the form of orders and
business commissioner icinga quoted that
figure recently so let's be very clear
limiting cohesion policy is populism
doesn't matter whether you call it pro
or anti European populism cohesion
policy and an ambitious fight with
disparities in the Union is a win-win
strategy something that's good for all
our members fighting inequality is
something that can be done through
transfers in the cohesion policy yes but
also by
bolstering our tax system closing
loopholes in the VAT system and clamping
down on tax havens in the EU v80 income
revenue is after all EU owned resources
the Commission has said that tax
avoidance and evasion is worth 200
billion euro a year and if you include
that it's 150 billion more than that
that is the big elephant in the room and
if it isn't and I don't know what is in
Poland we've managed to do this we have
dealt with VAT fraudsters who are
stealing v80 from our citizens including
lawyers officers who were avoiding
paying their taxes for years and who
were getting around a weak legal system
indeed the judiciary was particularly
passive in the face of these fraudsters
they often had very low penalties
sometimes suspended penalties and we
heard that it had to be like that there
was no way of challenging it but we've
shown that you can do something about
this we've done something positive for
Polish and European tax revenue we have
to set out what our goal is and then put
in place measures that will help us
achieve it and that's what we're
offering Europe a practical solution
that has already been tried and tested
we've talked about this in the Council
on a number of occasions mafia
terrorists and crooks stealing from
member states whose judiciary's don't
work properly is something that we've
shown you can fight against we've also
managed to pretty much eradicate poverty
in young people and children that's
another of our contributions within the
EU we also have to cooperate in order to
challenge tax avoidance like the digital
tax
tax havens I was talking with president
tne this morning and I talked about EU
own resources Poland supports the idea
that I know most of the European
Parliament supports that is that the EU
should have sufficient own resources
it's essentially therefore to restrict
tax havens not just individual countries
but their existence undermines the --use
existence because billions are leaking
out of our tax systems and that money
doesn't come back to citizens as a
result we chase text fraudsters or tax
evaders as an individual level and we
should therefore also be chasing up on
systemic or even state tax havens and
tax avoiders it seems logical to me that
we should have also a European
anti-monopoly office for dealing with
competition issues we need new
competition competition rules perhaps
also sectoral rules adapted to the
digital age Google and Facebook could be
described as part of essential
facilities or critical infrastructure
now the same as distribution
infrastructure in the energy market none
of us none of people in the room this
room could imagine life without these
instruments they're essential for
functioning in the digital age and our
legislative framework has to catch up
with that reality a new investment plan
has been put forward by President
Juncker and it has been a success growth
is up and the European strategic
investment fund has also generated
further investments in the amount of 300
billion euro we shouldn't limit
ourselves to that but we should also
transform it into a further ambitious
tool we need strategic investment not
just because we're coming out of a
crisis but so that we can be competitive
in the future
the European Investment Bank has warned
that the European Union is suffering
from a chronic lack of investment in
infrastructure where expenditure is
lower than it has been in many years the
investment holders or the investment gap
is six hundred billion euro and until
that hole is filled we're not going to
be able to compete with other global
powers another strategic goal is the
European energy transformation which
means linking competitiveness on price
with geopolitical realism what does that
mean what do we need we must invest in
innovation Europe needs to create the
biggest clean tech fund in the world and
make sure that the energy transition
becomes a rational proposition for
businesses around Europe these things
going to be essential if we're going to
be competitive in the future the
European route to a low-carbon economy
or even a zero emissions economy is
certainly a worthy goal I've got a road
to a clean environment and healthy
citizens perhaps in Poland where in
Poland we are aware of the importance of
this and that's why we've introduced
measures to clean up our air and fight
against smog however with the new
limitations that the EU was imposed I
call on you to remember that our
countries have started from a different
place in 1989 Poland's economy was based
on coal and heavy industry all the same
Poland made great efforts to meet the
emissions set out in the Kyoto Protocol
of 30 percent and we even though our
target originally we've only been 5
percent so we were six times better than
that we want to participate in the
energy transformation however it has to
be based on equality of opportunity and
take into account the differences
between our economies it also needs to
offer different instruments to support
the different member states for many
years
Poland didn't have the opportunity to
change to natural gas because it only
came from one direction from Russia any
attempt to use blue energy sources would
have been a risk to our national
security efforts in Eastern Europe could
all be undermined by the Nord Stream to
project this is not an economic project
it's a political project the European
Union doesn't need Nord Stream - it
brings with it a heightened risk of
instability in Eastern Europe and gives
Russia a great deal of influence on
European economics and policy so we have
to look at the reality of the European
of the global economy machine learning
the 4.0 Industrial Revolution innovation
all of these things can drive our
economy forward the internal combustion
engine has played a great role in
industrialization in the West that
Europe built up Airbus which Boeing is
the big global aviation player now we
need to do the same sort of thing in
technology Poland would like to take
part in this sort of project a vehicle
for reindustrialization in the 21st
century could be electro mobility this
is a project that's moving forward but
needs more support from Member States
only one and a half percent of cars in
Europe at the moment are electric cars
if we really want to bring emissions
down then we're going to have to make a
bigger steps forward it's not science
fiction to say that in 10 years 25% or
30% of cars could be electric cars in
the EU if we want the technologies of
the future to develop and we have to
continue developing the European capital
market particularly for SMEs
Poland supports that development on the
market
go growth can also be achieved through
intelligent growth development of the EU
economy and an adaptation of the EU
project now I said that the second point
was European security the second part of
this contract of citizens has to be
security in the last few years we've
seen a lot of geopolitical threats
terrorism the Russian hybrid war in
Ukraine and elsewhere interference in
the democratic process of countries of
the West and their events like what we
saw in Salisbury or Russians involvement
in Syria what Russia has done in the
Ukraine threatens the architecture of
Eastern Europe but it's aimed at
destabilizing the West Georgia was
subject to a similar attack a few years
ago and that shows clearly that what
Russia is doing is not coincidence but
part of a long-term strategy the only
fault inverted cars for these countries
was to choose a European economic and
political model and that shows the
European Eastern Partnership is
something that the whole EU needs to get
behind because it's essential for our
safety including that of our southern
countries and we want peace and
development on the borders of the EU as
well and Europe has to react with all
the means at its disposal to these
developments we also want to develop our
defence capacity the amount of money
that goes towards budget spending to
defense spending and NATO needs to be
increased this is a relationship that
has to be cultivated the power of the
West will always be its unity we should
deal with our disagreements in the in
the spirit of partnership after all it
was the America that helped in the first
and second world war and stopped the
Soviet Union from attacking Western
Europe the global imbalances that the
Americans are talking about are a fact
and they have to be dealt with at global
level
and therefore happy to see that the
European Defense Fund is being set up
and the whole pesky set up which is
going to be a supranational way of
investing in the defense sector this
will help us collaborate more closely
and develop defense technology cyber
security is another challenge in this
area we know that it's absolutely
crucial for democracies which can be
attacked through cybercrime during
elections no EU country is safe from
external interference and our citizens
aren't safe from that interference
either bank accounts and their whole
digital identity is under threat from
attack we have to fight together for
safety in the cyber space the council
summit last week ladies and gentlemen
has shown that the EU can be realistic
and can rebuild citizens trust citizens
who want safe borders and who want the
right to influence migration policy the
EU is dealing with a flow of migrants
from different directions and it's only
a flexible and intelligent approach to
the migration flows that we're going to
be able to rebuild citizens trust in the
EU Poland is the new home for one and a
half million Ukrainians Ukrainians many
of whom have escaped from Russian
aggression in eastern Ukraine
they may not be registered in Poland as
refugees but that's simply because
administrative Lee it's very easy for
them to get work permits and build their
lives through supporting our and the use
economies through work migration from
the Middle East and Africa
is going to increase and that's why the
EU must react creating stable
stabilisation and development in those
regions
we need a new Marshall Plan for Europe
for Africa and we need also to combat
illegal human trafficking towards Europe
the EU emergency trust fund for Africa
is one instrument but we would propose
more a European Development Fund for
Africa Poland would like to give the
fishing rod rather than the fish to
Africa and we would be happy to
contribute in a disproportionately high
amount as compared to our GDP this is
not just a declaration but we're also
involved in the European resilience
initiative the European Union is the
greatest success of Europe since the
Second World War
now we have to look again at renewing
the EU contract with the citizens to
guarantee security and prosperity so let
me say something about the third point I
raised earlier namely socially just
European Union for citizens we can't
forget one fundamental principle that
our community is based on social justice
that principle is the overriding
principle of our society and it can be
found in the EU treaty and the Polish
Constitution these are not just hollow
words you can't talk about social
development unless you deal with
exclusion poverty and inequality when we
it's important that we have ambitious
social policy to fight these
inequalities
what we've achieved in the last two and
a half years in Poland shows that if you
change the paradigm you can change the
paradigm and that our strategy has
brought excellent effects we have
unemployment under 4% according to
Eurostat public debt has fallen for the
first time in 30 years the budget
deficit is shrinking and at the same
time we have the most ambitious social
policy since the fall of communism and
the victory of solidarity
we're also cutting red tape for SMEs and
citizens we're reducing taxes but only
for small and medium-sized companies not
for big corporations we're also creating
a sound financial policy by tackling the
Mafia tax fraudsters and by closing
loopholes in the tax system we've also
created the biggest support system for
technology and information in Eastern
Europe populist capitalism means
innovation and solidarity the
liberalisation of trade has created
economic growth and it can't be
contemned out of hand however economic
growth hasn't been to the benefit of
everybody to the same degree I'm not
talking about protectionism the way to
deal with inequality is to invest in
human capital education determines
people's future earnings we must invest
in human capital and that ties to the
second challenge that we are linked to
autumn ization and robotize ation I'm
not going to suggest that we have people
working in all posts in the 21st century
or block innovation however there is a
fear that people will be made unemployed
by robots and we have to address that
fear technological progress will create
a demand for new professions but they
will be a different type of job than
those in the past they will require for
example high level of skills and that
requires a high level of education
robotize ation will mean that capital
will be more important in creating jobs
and businesses and we must make sure
that capital is distributed fairly as
would be the revenue from that business
Thomas Piketty has shown that capital is
very concentrated and combat
concentration will continue to intensify
digitization has led to a
winner-takes-all distribution of wealth
fewer people are taking more of the
profit the digital age the platform
economy create an opportunity for
Napoles the network effect has led to
global Giants who don't have any
competition we must count Kombat
inequality in the EU and that's really
one of the big arguments that we can put
in the current debate on an EU budget we
need new policies for these new
challenges but their funding shouldn't
be done at the expense of cohesion and
social policy which is fundamental to
the EU and to the treaty provisions the
example of Poland in the last
two-and-a-half years have shown that if
you take the right strategy you can
change both societies and the economy
the European Union can be a symbol of
European dreams once again but this is
only going to be possible if we make the
right choice and if we can overcome
divisions and if we can remember that
despite our divisions we are joined by
European identity in the European
Parliament we've heard about European
sovereignty yes
Europe should be an entity on the global
stage defending its interests it should
be powerful so as to better defend our
interests how
a European sovereignty cannot mean
building up Europe at the expense of the
force of member states because the force
of a sovereign Europe comes from the
force of its member states weak member
states and countries who feel they're
being ignored would be a recipe for
indifference to the EU in which the EU
is a problem and not a solution Poland
will do its utmost to make sure that
that scenario doesn't happen the EU is
an important way of building solidarity
prosperity and security for us
John Paul the second said that at the
root of a united Europe there were two
lungs an Eastern lung and a Western lung
and that they were both important for
the old continent ladies and gentlemen
the European Union is an open book and
we all have at least one page to write
in that book it's not a finished piece
of work
but a Houston the first director of the
Commission said in 1963 and a speech
called Europe under construction said
that Europe is a living organism that is
continued developing and with that in
mind we shouldn't engage in determinism
that says there's only one future for
the EU and forcing us to transfer
competences from national level to EU
level until we end up with some sort of
super super state bu the EU is an
international experiment looking for
solutions that weren't available to
member nation states discussion
cooperation negotiation this is the DNA
of the European project on the basis of
those rules we have the foundations that
were laid by De Gasperi Adenauer
Schumann and Jean Monnet the founding
fathers we shouldn't try to gene-spliced
the nature of the EU therefore but
rather look for new ways to work
together to guarantee security and
development for our countries and
prosperity for our societies integration
was never a goal in itself for the EU it
was simply to guarantee peace prosperity
development democracy and justice the
European community is now at a junction
where it has to listen to what its
citizens are saying to it
rapping up let me conclude by saying we
have to listen to citizens concern we
have to hear the hope that they still
hold out for the EU we need to guarantee
them security development solidarity and
peace Europe has to be open to citizens
giving everyone an equal chance and
showing solidarity to the vulnerable a
united Europe in the face of threats
which respects the will of nation-states
the European Parliament is the best
institution to have the citizens voice
heard and understood for the good of
free nation-states and for the good of
the future of the EU thank you
[Applause]